[موسيقى]
مساء الخير تطورات كبيره مرتقبه في
الاسابيع المقبله في المواجهه الدائره بين
روسيا والغربه على الاراضي
الاخرانيهم استراتيجيه عسكريه جديده هذه
الاستراتيجيه وضعت الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها في مفترق طرق وامام خيارات
المصريه اما التخلي عن اوكرانيا وخساره
الحرب لصالح الروس او مواصله دعمهم
للاكران والمخاطره بمصالحهم وامنهم القومي
كيف ولماذا هذا يتطلب بدايه ان نعرف ما هي
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه الجديده
والاستراتيجيه الروسيه في اوكرانيا في اقل
عدد من الكلمات هو الانتقال من عمليه
عسكريه محدوده الى حرب بن تن
كان الروس من اندلاع الحرب في 24 فبراير
وحتى منتصف اكتوبر الماضي يبنون كل
تحركاتهم العسكريه على اساس عمليه عسكريه
محدوده تكفي لتحقيق كل اهدافهم وما هي
الاهداف الروسيه في اوكرانيا تحدثنا عنها
قبل ذلك كثيره ولكن يمكن اختصارها في
اختطاع الدوله الاخرانيه للنفوذ الروسي من
خلال عده اشكال ابسطها اسقاط حكومه زلنسكي
والقوميون الاوكران المعادين للرؤوس
وتعيين حكومه مواليه لموسكو سواء حققوا
ذلك او قاموا باحتلال شرق اوكرانيا او
ناجحوا في همم يعني منح شرق اوكرانيا
جمهوريه شرق اوكرانيا استقلالا ذاتيا او
حتى انفصالا كاملا ايا كانت الاهداف كان
الروسي يعتقدون انه يمكن ان تتحقق بعمليه
عسكريه محدوده لكن بعد مضيء نحو سته اشهر
ادرك الروس ان هذه الاستراتيجيه فاشله ولا
يمكن ان يحققه اهدافهم اذا حاربوا بربع
رئه
وادركوا ايضا انهم لم يفشلوا فقط في تحقيق
اهدافهم بل مونيو بمجموعه من الخسائر
المحرجه على يد الجيش الاوكراني المشحون
بالدوافع والمدعوم بقوه من حلف شمال
الاطلسي وبدات مطالب الاوكران تتطور
وتحركاتهم العسكريه تتقدم
وبداوا همم يهاجمون الجيش الروسي ليس فقط
على خطوط المواجهه همم الموجوده على طول
الجبهه ما بين شرق اوكرانيا وغرب اوكرانيا
دول طوروا الهجمات لتكون في عمق شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمها الاخران منذ 2014 واحيانا
بادره بالهجوم على بعض الاهداف داخل روسيا
الاتحاديه نفسها وارتفعت مطالب الاوكران
الذين رفضوا او باته يرفضون الجلوس على
مائده المفاوضات في ظل حكومه الرئيس بوتن
ايريدون تغييرا في النظام واذا جلسوا على
مائده المفاوضات يريدون انسحاب الروس ليس
فقط من الاراضي التي احتلتها بعد 24
فبراير الماضي
ولكن العوده لحدود 1991 اي جلاء الروس عن
شبه جزيره القرم شبه جزيره القرم التي
ضمها الروس في 2014 والتي يعتبروها الروس
وجزءا اصيلا من روسيا بلوي يعتبروها بعض
الروس ارضا مقدسه لماذا ارضا مقدسه قصه
يطول شرحها لكن بعض روس يقولون اذا كان
الغرباء لا يفهمون ما هي شبه جزيره القرم
لكثير من الروس فليعتبروها مثل القدس
للمسلمين ولي الفلسطينيين او مثل القدس
للاسرائيليين ولليهود
[تصفيق]
وبسبب كل هذه ال ال ال ال ال التغيرات بدا
بدا الكلام بدا الرئيس بوتن وقادته يعيدون
النظر في الاستراتيجيه التي اتبعوها منذ
بدايه الحرب ولم تحقق اهدافهم
الاستراتيجيه الجديده تتمثل زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم في تطوير الهجوم ليكون حرب شامله
وبدات هذه الحرب الشامله من منتصف اكتوبر
الماضي لكن تم تمهيد لها باجراءات اتخذت
على مدار الاسابيع السابقه لها اي بدايه
من سبتمبر لما اعلن عن تعبئه جزئيه وتجنيد
نحو 300,000 جند روسي جديد ثم خطاب الرئيس
بوتين الذي محد فيه الشعب الروسي لحرب
طويله سوف يستخدم فيها كل الوسائل الممكنه
لحمايه الاراضي الروسيه تعريف الرئيس قتل
للاراضي الروسيه همم شامل وكبير لانه
بيشمل اراضي رسل اتحاديه طبعا شبه جزيره
القرم طبعا بالاضافه الى اربعه اقاليم
ضماها حديثا من الاراضي الاخرانيه وهي
جمهوريتي الضمباز وذابورياشيا وخرسون التي
قام بضمها بعد استفتاء لم تعترف به معظم
دول العالم في 30 سبتمبر الماضي
الاستراتيجيه الجديده احتاجت الى جنرال
جديد وبالفعل قام بتعيين قائد عام جديد
للجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا وهو سيرجي همم
سرفين همم سرغي الصرافيكين همم اسمه معروف
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط لانه تولى قياده
القوات الروسيه في سوريا وتحدث عنه الغرب
كثيرا طبعا عاده بشكل سلبي وتصويره على ان
رجل الدموي الى اخره ولكن دي قصه يعني همم
يعني ليست موضوعنا على كل حال سرجي حين
جاء لتنفيذ الاستراتيجيه الجديده طبعا كان
لديه القناعه الواضحه انه من سبقوه
استخدمه اا قبضه همم رخوه لتحقيق اهداف
غير واقعيه الاهداف غير الواقعيه ديت هي
بسطه سيطرتهم على اوكرانيه باقل قدر ممكن
من الخسائر على اعتبار ان توظيف اوكرانيه
ليست الا دوله مارقه
احتاج الى قرصه اذن خفيفه لاعادتها الى
بيت الطاعه الروسي
هذا كان خطا وحان وقت التصحيح تصحيح
الاوضاع بالتعامل مع اوكرانيا على انها
دوله عدو ويجب استخدام كل وسائل القوه
لهذه
لتحقيق كل الاهداف الروسيه ولا يمكن تحقيق
كل الاهداف الروسيه وهزيمه اوكرانيا الا
بتحييد الجيش الروسي الا بتحيد الجيش
الاوكراني كيف يمكن ان تحيد الجيش
الاوكراني باقل قدر ممكن من الخسائر في
الجيش الروسي اللي موني بقدر كبير جدا من
الخسائر في الارواح وفي المعدات بضرب
البنيه التحتيه الحرجه وما هي البنيه
التحتيه الحرجه هي كل الدنيا التحتيه التي
لا يمكن الاستغناء عنها الاستمرار الحياه
يعني وسائل المواصلات محطات المياه
الانترنت المستشفيات المصانع محطه الصرف
الصحي الى اخره
ولكنه لم يكن في حاجه لضرب كل هذه الاهداف
المدنيه بالدرجه الاولى يكفي جدا ان يسيطر
على محطات الطاقه فاذا ضرب محطات الطاقه
بالدرجه الاولى سوف يحدث ما شرحه لي
اللواء
الدكتور التيار هشام الحلبي
سوف يحدث الاثر التتابعي يتم ضرب محطات
الكهرباء
فتتوقف تلقائيا شبكات معالجه الصرف الصحي
ومحطه المياه وشبكات الاتصالات
والمستشفيات والمصانع باختصار يتم شل
الاقتصاد والحياه المدنيه او النشاط
الاقتصادي على وجه التحديد الاوكراني لانه
لا يوجد نشاط اقتصادي بدون كهرباء بدون
طاقه اذا تم شل الحياه الاقتصاديه سوف
يؤثر ذلك بشكل ضخم جدا على الجيش
الاوكراني الذي يحارب على تخوم المدن كما
يعني اوضح الواقع شامل الحلبي لان في فرق
ان انت تحارب مثلا في صحراء او على الحدود
فبتستخدم ادوات مختلفه عن جيش بيحارب داخل
المدن وعلى تخوم المدن
هل استخدام هذا التكتيك وضرب البنيه
التحتيه الحرجه وخصوصا المحطات الكهرباء
او الطاقه استراتيجيه جديده اخترعها سيرجي
سرهوفكين الاجابه لا هو استراتيجيه معروفه
وضرب محطه الطاقه على وجه التحديد هدف
مغري متبع لكل الجيوش المتحاربه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه والى الان وعاده لما
دوله
بتستهدف المنشات الحيويه او محطه الطاقه
في دوله اخرى بتكون عندها اربع اهداف
المعروفه الهدف الاول ضرب الروح المعنويه
للمدنيين اللي حياتهم بتشل تقريبا ثم فرد
ثمن باهر على السياسيين اذا ارادوا
الاستمرار في هذه الحرب الرساله عاوزين
تستمر في الحرب التكلفه سوف تكون عنيفه
الان ولا عشرات السنوات المقبله لاننا سوف
نعيدكم الى ما قبل القرن ال 19
الهدف الثالث طبعا تشتيت الجهود الحربيه
للجيش اللي كان مثلا الجيش الاوكراني
مشغول بصد الهجوم الهجمات الروسيه او
تطهير او تطوير هجمات مباغته على القوات
الروسيه في اماكن مختلفه اصبح مشغولا
بحمايه اهداف رغوه منتشره في طول البلاد
وعرضها محطه مياه هنا محطه كهرباء هناك
محطه صرف حيويه الى اخره والاهم من كل ذلك
الهدف الرابع وهو اضعاف او ايقاف ماكينه
همم الحرب اللي هو همم يعني الضرب الانتاج
الحربي ما هي تصنيع المعدات العسكريه او
على الاقل الصيانات هي بيتطلب مصانع
والمصانع العسكريه مثل المصانع المدنيه لا
يمكن ان تعمل بدون كهرباء لا يمكن ان تعمل
بشكل فعال بدون شبكات كهرباء مستقله كثير
من المعدات العسكريه اصلا ومنها بطاريات
الدفاع الجو بيعتمد على شبكات الكهرباء
العامه
هل ضرب المنشات الحيويه هو كل ما في جعبه
القائد العسكري الجديد حقيقه الامر الجيش
الاوكراني المسؤولين الاخراني يخشون ان
هناك الكثير جدا في جعبته
اربعه الكبار الاربعه الكبار همم في
اوكرانيا تحدثوا في منتصف هذا الشهر من هم
الاربعه الكبار الرئيسكي
وزير الدفاع قائد الجيش وقائد العمليات
البريه الاربعه تحدثوا الى صحف بريطانيه
وتحديدا مجله الاقامه ثلاثه تتكلم عليهم
في نفس التوقيت تقريبا
الاربعه لما تقرا كلامهم ولا وضع لحضراتكم
روابط حواراتهم المهمه جدا
بيدمعوا على شيء واحد فقط وان الضربات
العسكريه التي شناها الجنرال الجديد
ليس هدفها فقط ضرب
القدرات الاوكرانيه وشل الحياه المدنيه
وابطاء العمليات العسكريه هذه سوف تكون
مرحله مؤقته بعدها يستعد الجيش الروسي
اثناء وهيست- يسترد الجيش الروسي انفاسه
ومنظم صفوفه ثم يستعد في هجوم بري شامل
على المدن الاوكرانيه وان هذا الهجوم سوف
يكون في يناير او فبراير المقبلين وان
اوضاع الجيش الاوكراني اسوا بكثير مما
يعتقد حلفاؤه في الغرب واننا لا نستطيع ان
نصمد ونصد هذه الهجمات المحتمله الا بتعمل
غير مسبوق من الغرب وتحديدا للولايات
المتحده اعطيكم كلام
قائد الجيش الاوكراني فلاري زالوجيني
اختصارا للوقت كلهم قالوا كلاما مشابها بس
ازاله جيني قال ايه شرح الوضع العسكري
وشرح انه القوات الروسيه تحت الاستراتيجيه
الجديده بتضغط بطول 1500 كيلو متر اللي هو
الخط الفاصل ما بين المدن والاقاليم التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا والاقاليم التي ما زالت
خاطئه للجيش الاوكراني
وبيقول انه وراء هذا الخط الالف 15 كيلو
متر معلوماتنا ان الجيش الروسي يستعد ينظم
صفوف للشن هجوم علينا في الشتاء وانه قادر
على الهجوم علينا بمليون و200 او مليون
و500,000 جندي لكن على الارجح سوف يكتفي
الروس بالهجوم علينا بمئتين الف جندي فقط
وبيضيف اعلم انني استطيع هزيمه هذا العدو
افتح قوسين الاوكراني لديهم حوالي 700 الف
جندي تحت السلاح يعني يقدر يحارب ب 700
الف جندي لكنه يكتفي الان بالقتال ب 200
الف جندي ما يعني ان هناك تكافؤ في العدد
بين الجنود الاوكران وبين من يحارب بهم
الروس حتى الان
ولكن ما ينقصني والكلام لي قائد الجيش
الاوكراني هو المعدات انا في حاجه الى
المعدات كل ما احتاجه هو السلاح ثم السلاح
ثم السلاح واشار الى عدد القطع العسكريه
التي يحتاجها
فيست قال احتاج الى 300 دبابه ومن 600 الى
700 مركبه قتال مشاه و500 مدفع همم بشكل
عاجل طبعا هذا خلاف المعدات المتقدمه التي
لم يذكرها في هذا الحوار ولكن ذكروها قبل
ذلك كثيرا وذكرتها وسائل الاعلام ومسؤولين
غربيين باختصار بالاضافه الى هذه الاسلحه
التقليديه المهمه الاخران بيطلبوا من
الغرب كل ما يمكن ان يقدمه واخر ما طالبه
كانت بطاريات هاتفيه للدفاع الجوي اللي
البيت الابيض قال انه يبحث بامكانيه
تقديمها وهذه قصه اخرى يمكن ان نتحدث عنها
في حينها لكن بعض الخبراء العسكريين جمعوا
عدد القطع اللي طلبها الجيش الرئيس الجيش
الاوكراني علنا وجدوها 1500 دبابه ومركبه
موشا ومدفع وجدوا ان 1500 قطعه ديت اكبر
من كل الاسلحه المدرعه الموجوده تقريبا في
همم معظم دول اوروبا يعني
عدد ضخم جدا وضخامه العدد بتزداد اذا
اضفنا هذه الكميه الهائله من التسليح الى
كل ما حصل عليه الاوكران من حلف شمال
الاطلسي ومن الولايات المتحده خلال ال 10
اشهر الماضيه امريكا وحدها
وفي اول ثلاثه شهور فقط قدمت الى اوكرانيا
مساعدات قيمته 54 مليار دولار هذا الرقم
في اول ثلاثه شهور من الولايات المتحده
وحدها ليس اقل بكثير من اجمالي الميزانيه
العسكريه الروسيه الثانويه قبل الحرب اللي
كانت بتتراوح من 65 الى 70 مليار دولار
سنويا
على العموم الرساله من كل المسؤولين في
اوكرانيا نستطيع ان نتغلب على الهجمات
الصاروخيه نستطيع ان نواجه الهجوم الروسي
الذي نترقبه همم في بدايه الشتاء في يناير
فبراير المقبلين فقط اذا اعطيتمونا ما
نحتاجه من سلاح ومن نحتاجه من سلاح كثير
جدا المطالب الاوكرانيه بالنسبه للغرب
يعني
احد القرارين التاليين عدم الاستجابه
للمطالب الاوكراني لانها سوف تجر الغرب
الى منعطف خطير جدا جدا واذا لم يستجيب
للمطالب الاوكرانيه وفقا للتصور الاوكراني
سوف نخسر الحرب واذا خسرنا الحرب سوف
تنتصر روسيا وسوف يكون لذلك توابع كثيره
ليس على اوكرانيا فقط ولكن على دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي وعلى ما كانت الولايات
المتحده وعظمى ولكن اذا استجاب الغرب اذا
استجابت الولايات المتحده سوف تكون لهذه
الاستجابه تواب خطيره منها ان تنفذ
مخزوناتهم من الاسلحه وهذا امر لم يعد سرا
الاتحاد الاوروبي بيتحدث علنا عن نفاذ
مخزوناته من كثير من الاسلحه
الولايات المتحده بتتحدث عن خطر نفاد كثير
من الاسلحه من المخازن الامريكيه
وهذا يعني انه في حاله تطور الصراع سوف
يواجه الغرب سوف تواجه واشنطن روسيا
بخزائن فارغه طب ما هي روسيا كمان مجهده
اه صحيح لكن هم بيتكلموا على تامين جانبهم
ولذلك في دراسات كثيره وفي خبراء كثيره
بيقولوا ان من ينتصر في هذه الحرب على
المدى الطويل ان استمرت ومن يستطيع توفير
الاسلحه الاستمرار الحرب ولكن ايضا هذه
القصه يمكن ان نتابعها في وقت لاحق
المساله مش هتبقى بس ان هم بيخاطروا
بامداد الاوكران بمخزون حيوي جدا من اسلحه
لا يستطيعون تعويضها بشكل سريع ان اشتعلت
المواجهه بينهم وبين الروس بشكل مباشر
ولكن الخوف من رد فعل الروسي من امداد
اوكرانيا بهذا القدر الهائل من الاسلحه
هائل
كيف يمكن ان يتعامل الروس مع تفوق اوكراني
بسبب اسلحه غربيه كثيره ومتفوقه هربا من
هزيمه محتمله قد يقرر الروس وهذا منطقي
مواجهه الموقف والهروب من الهزيمه
باستخدام سلاح النووي وتحدث الكارثه
المساله واضحه جدا الروس اوضحه موقفه لن
نخسر هذه الحرب مهما تكلفنا مهما تكلف
الامر الاوكران موقفهم واضح جدا لن نتنازل
طائعين عن شبر واحد من اراضينا
بقي موقف الغرب الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
ما هو موقفهم اذا وصلوا دعمهم لاوكرانيا
هذا يعني انهم يخاطرون
بمصالحهم بكثير جدا من مصالحهم القوميه لا
يوجد مصلحه واحده للولايات المتحده يمكن
ان تتحقق بحرب مع الروس مصالح امريكا كلها
تتحقق باستنزاف الروس
استنزاف الروس يتطلب حرب لا يعني لا تشارك
فيها الولايات المتحده مباشره اي مصلحه
يمكن ان تاتي الى ذهنك مصالح اقتصاديه
ضيقه زي بيع المزيد من الغاز مزيد من
الاسلحه تتحقق فقط الى استمرت الحرب دون
مشاركه الامريكان مصالح استراتيجيه زي
مثلا احكام السيطره على الاوروبيين
وابقائهم همم تابعين القرار الولايات
المتحده المصالح اكثر حيويه زي اضعاف
الجيش الروسي وبقى حرمان همم الصين من قوه
الجيش الروسي في اي مواجهه مستقبله كل
مستقبلا كل هذه الاهداف تتحقق فقط
باستمرار حرب بشكل محدود ومنهج للروس لكن
لا يمكن ان تتحقق
بحرب المتسعه تشتبك فيها الولايات المتحده
مع الروس يعني
وبالتالي خلال الاسابيع المقبله المنتظر
ان تتخذ واشنطن قرارات واضحه همم تتعلق
بحسن اهدافها من هذه الحرب ماذا تريد منها
وبالتالي تحدد مدى سوف تصنع هل تستجيب
للمطالب الاخرانيه ان تحجم عنها وترفضها
وفي الحالتين هناك ثواب خطيره على الغرب
ومعها ان شاء الله يكون لنا حلقات اخرى
باذن الله ونتابعها بالتفصيل اشكركم والى
اللقاء